the world is an unpredictable place
that's what makes it so haunting when
you watch a movie years after it's come
out and you realize that the filmmakers
unintentionally predicted real-world
tragedies you'll never be able to watch
these movies the same way again
Game of Death Game of Death was released
in 1978 five years after its lead actor
Bruce Lee had died but the completed
movie which was rewritten after Lee died
of unrelated medical complications
during the production contains a truly
eerie plot point Lee plays Billy Lowe an
actor who shot with a prop gun that
turns out to have a real bullet in it
the shot isn't fatal but Lowe fakes his
death to take revenge on the would-be
assassins in 1993 Bruce Lee's son
Brandon Lee died while filming The Crow
an actor was supposed to fire an
unloaded gun at Brandon but a bullet
fragment that was previously stuck in
the barrel dislodged while shooting the
blank cartridge it struck Brandon with
the same velocity as a real round
Brandon Lee died under nearly the same
circumstances depicted in his father's
final movie demolition men demolition
man from 1993 predicted a high-profile
murder nearly a decade before it
happened the sci-fi film involved a
cryoprison where criminals are frozen
and put in cold storage at one point in
the movie the prisoners who are frozen
with Stallone's character and the
criminal he caught appear on a jailhouse
monitor one of the names that pops up is
Scott Peterson a name probably chosen by
an intern or low-level production
assistant fewer than 10 years later in
2002 a woman named Lacey Peterson was
brutally murdered by her husband Scott
Peterson he was convicted of killing
Lacey and their unborn son in 2004 and
was sentenced to death a year later in
the years after his conviction and
sentencing he was a death row inmate in
California's San Quentin prison
meanwhile the cryoprison and demolition
man was where California kept their
worst prisoners their death row inmates
the matrix to say the prop designer on
the set of the matrix from 1999 may have
inadvertently predicted the worst act of
terror inflicted on the United States of
America is both unnerving and more
importantly not meant to show disrespect
to any of the Fallen however when
watching the movie now it's difficult to
ignore the expiration date on Thomas neo
Anderson's passport which is 9 1101
poltergeist poltergeist is spooky enough
but it doesn't end there the children's
room includes a fake Super Bowl 22
poster which would be happening in 1988
six years after the movie debuted in
theaters weirdly enough that poster
inadvertently predicted when Heather
O'Rourke the child star who's abducted
by ghosts in the movie would become
fatally sick as Super Bowl 22 came
around on January 31st 1988 O'Rourke
fell violently ill before passing away
the next day due to a cardiac arrest
triggered by an intestinal stenosis
World's Greatest Dad
in 2009 World's Greatest Dad Robin
Williams plays Lance Clayton a dad and
English teacher whose teenage son
accidentally dies from autoerotic
asphyxiation Clayton not wanting the
police or anyone else to find his son's
body like that makes it look like a
suicide instead Williams's portrayal of
Clayton combined with his heartfelt
characters who dealt with suicide and
what dreams may come
patch Adams and Dead Poets Society makes
his tragic suicide in 2014 stand out
even more thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw